[音楽]
今日はAI
コーディングエージェントの品質問題について話していくぜ。
品質問題?AI
が書いたコードってそんなに問題あるの?
実はその問題を今コから解決するフレームワークが今めちゃくちゃ注目されてるんだ。
へえ。それは気になるわね。
その名もスーパーパワーズ。なんと公開からわずか
5ヶ月で9万6000
スターを獲得した怪物プロジェクトだぜ。それじゃあスーパーパワーズを詳しく見ていくぜ。
ゆっくりしていってね。
それじゃあまずはリポジ取りの基本情報から見ていこう。
9万6000
スター。それに主要言語がシェルスクリプトなのね。
[音楽]
そう。スーパーパワーズは行動画ツールじゃなくて
AI
エージェントの行動を制御するフレームワークなんだ。だからシェルスクリプトとマークダウンで構成されてる。
AIの行動を制御する。どういうこと?
つまりクロードコードやカーソルみたいな
AI
コーディングエージェントにちゃんとした開発プロセスを強制するわけだ。ライセンスも
MITで安心だぜ。
でもさ、AI
が書いたコードって普通に動くことが多いし、そんなに問題ある?
一見動くように見えるのが厄介なんだよ。テストがないから
からリファクタリングした時にデグレが起きることも多いんだ。
ああ、それは分かるかも。AI
に欠かせた部分を変更したら別の機能が壊れてたことあるわ。
しかもAI
エージェントって言われたことをすぐ実装しようとするだろ。設計もせずにいきなり行動を書き始める。
[音楽]
確かにこの機能作ってって言ったらすぐ行動生成しちゃうわよね。
それが問題なんだ。
人間のエンジニアならまず要件を確認して設計を考えてテストを書いてから実装するだろ。
理想はそうだけどAI
にそこまで求められるの。
それを可能にするのがスーパーパワーズなんだぜ。まずはスーパーパワーズがどれだけ注目されているかスター
[音楽]
3を見てみよう。
え、この伸び方すごくない。
2025年10月に公開されて1
月中旬から一気に爆発してるわ。
ピーク時には1日で2400
スター以上を獲得する日もあったんだ。まさに爆発的な成長だぜ。
なんでそんなに急に伸びたの?[音楽]
AI
コーディングエージェントが急速に普及する中で品質管理の課題が表面化してきたタイミングだったんだ。
[音楽]
つまりみんなが同じ悩みを抱えてたってことね。
そういうこと。スーパーパワーズはその課題にぴったりの解決策を提供したわけだ。ここで
AI
コーディングエージェントの課題を整理してみよう。
さっきの品質問題の話ね。
まず第1にAI
はテストを書かない。言われない限りテストなしで行動を量産するんだ。
言われなきゃ書かないのは人間も同じかも。
第2に[音楽]AI
は設計を省略する。いきなり実装に飛びつくから全体の整合性が取れなくなる。そして第
3にチームでAI
ツールを使うと使い方がバラバラで開発プロセスが続人化するんだ。
[音楽]
なるほど。便利なツールなのに使い方次第では逆に問題を生むのね。
じゃあスーパーパワーズがこの問題をどう解決するか主要機能を紹介していくぜ。
段階のワークフロー結構しっかりしてるわね。
まずブレインストーミングから始まるんだ。
AIがきなり行動を書かずにまず何を作りたいのかを深掘りしてくれる。
要件ページ定時からやってくれるのね。使用駆動開発ができるツールは他にもあるけど、スーパーパワーズならではの強みってあるの?
スーパワーズの強みはスキルが場面に応じて自動的にトリカーされる点だ。手動で指示しなくても設計が必要な時はグレストが起動し、実装面では
TDD
が起動する。設計が承認されたら次はギットのワークツリーで隔離された作業環境を作って実装計画を立てる。
[音楽]
ワーク釣りって何?
簡単に言うと元のプロジェクトを汚さずに実験できるコピーみたいなもんだ。失敗しても安心だぜ。
便利ね。で、実装はどうやるの?[音楽]
ここで重要なのがTDD
テスト駆動開発だ。普通は行動を書いてからテストを書くけど、
TDD
は逆で先にテストを書いてから実装するんだ。
先にテストを書くの?なんで?
テストを先に書くと何を作るべきかが明確になるからだ。ゴールを決めてから走る感覚だな。そしてスーパーパワーズはこの
TDDに鉄の置き手を設けてる。
テストを書く前に行動を書いたらその行動全部削除されるんだぜ。
[音楽]
全部削除。参考として残すのもダメなの?
ダメなんだ。参考として残すのもちらみするのも禁止。テストから書き直せがルールだぜ。
厳しいけど、それくらいしないとTDD
は定着しないのかもね。
さらにサブエージェント駆動開発っていう仕組みがある。
AI
ってコンテキストが長くなると判断力が落ちるからタスクごとに新しい
を呼び出して余計な情報に引きずられないようにしてるんだ。
2段階レビューって
最初に仕様通りに実装されてるかチェックして次にコードの品質をチェックする。両方通らないと次のタスクに進めない仕組みだぜ。じゃあ実際にどんな場面で役立つか使用例を紹介するぜ。まずはスタートアップのエンジニアの場合。
AI
で高速開発してたけどテストがなくてバグだらけだった人がスーパーパワーズを導入した。
どんな状況だったの?
リリースするたびにデグレが発生して夜中にバグ対応する日が続いてたらしい。
[音楽]
それは辛いわね。
でもスーパーパワーズを入れたらGDD
が強制されるからテストなしのコードが存在できなくなった。結果としてデレデグレがほぼなくなって安心してリリースできるようになったんだ。
[音楽]
開発速度は落ちないの?
むしろ手戻りが減った分トータルでは早くなったらしいぜ。
次に大企業のテックリードの場合。
10人のチームでAI
ズールを使ってたけど使い方がバラバラで困ってたんだ。
人によってAI
への指示の出し方が全然違うのよね。
スーパーパワーズを全員に導入したら同じ
段階ワークフローで動くからレビュー基準も統一されて寝質のばらつきがなくなったんだ。
チーム開発の標準化にはすごく効果的ね。
ここで大事なことを言っておくぜ。スーパーパワーズは
AIを賢告する魔法じゃない。
え、違うの?
人間のエンジニアが本来やるべき正しい開発プロセスを
AIにも守らせるための仕組みなんだ。
つまりAI
に丸投げじゃなくて人間側もちゃんと気想分かってないとダメってことね。
最後にAI
エージェント開発を研究する学生の場合、
種類のスキル設計を分析して論文にまとめたらしい。
具体的にどんなスキルが面白いの?
例えばシステマチックでバッキングっていうスキルはバグの根本原因を
4段階のプロセスで突き止めるんだ。
バーチャリ的な修正じゃなくて体型的に分析するのね。
そう。こういうスキルの設計思想を分析することで
AI
エージェントをどう制御すべきかの事件が得られる。今まさにホットな研究テーマだぜ。
[音楽]
ところで似たようなツールって他にもあるの?クロード
MDとかで指示書を書くのとどう違うの?
いい質問だな。クロードMD
は性的な指示書だから書いたルールがそのまま適用されるだけなんだ。
[音楽]
それで十分じゃないの?
スーパータパワーズは違う。スキルが状況に応じて自動的にトリガーされるんだ。設計が必要な場面ではグレインストーミングが起動し、実装場面では
TDDが起動する。同的な制御だぜ。
[音楽]
なるほど。スマートホームみたいなものね。
帰宅したら自動で証明がつくみたいに場面に合わせて適切なスキルが動く。
そうそう。まさにそんなイメージだ。それにエイダーみたいなコーディング補助とも違う。
どう違うの?
エイダーは行動画作業を手伝ってくれるけど、スーパーパワーズは開発プロセス全体を管理する。設計からテストレビューまでカバーしてるんだ。
役割が全然違うのね。併用もできそう。
そうだな。あとスーパーワズの最大の強みはクロード、コード、カーソル、コーデックス、オープンコード、ジェミにノイツつのプラットフォームに対応してることだ。
[音楽]
使ってみたくなってきた。どうやってインストールするの?
クロードコードなら公式マーケットプレイスからワンコマンドでインストールできるぜ。スプラグインストールパズ@ルで完了だ。
[音楽]
簡単ね。カーソルの場合は
カーソルもプラグインマーケットプレイズからスーパーワーズで検索すれば見つかるぜ。
[音楽]
インストールしたら何か特別な設定は必要なの?
実はそれが最高のポイントなんだ。
インストールするだけでスキルが自動的にトリガーされるから特別な操作は一切不要だぜ。
何もしなくてもAI
に起立る開発が自動適用されるのね。それはすごい。
[音楽]
さて今日のまとめだ。スーパーズは
AI
コーディングエージェントに体型的な開発プロセスを自動で強制するフレームワークだ。
[音楽]
テストなしのコードは全作削除っていう鉄の置き手がインパクト大きかったわ。
段階のワークフロー14
種類のスキルサブエージェント駆動開発。
5ヶ月で9万6000
スターを獲得したのも納得だぜ。
AI
エージェントは便利だけど寝質管理なしでは危険ってことがよくわかったわ。
概要欄にリポジ取りのリンクを貼っておくから是非インストールして試してみてくれ。
この動画が参考になったらいいねとチャンネル登録もお願いね。
それじゃあまたな。
[音楽]